threats to international peace and
security
in accordance with rule 37 of the
council's provisional rules of procedure
in accordance with rule 39 of the
council's provisional rules or procedure
i invite the following briefers
to participate in this meeting
mr martin griffith under secretary
general for humanitarian affairs and
emergency relief coordinator catherine
and miss catherine russell
executive director of the united nations
children's fund
it is so decided
the security council will now begin its
consideration of item 2 of the agenda
thank you very much madam president
and congratulations on
presiding over this
council
um
in these extraordinary times
we're here of course to speak about the
humanitarian situation in ukraine and
yet
none of us
want to be here today
we already had enough on our hands many
other
unnecessary and unwanted conflicts
leaving misery
in their wake we had no need for another
war
which would have such a swift and
sweeping impact for what
filippo grandi has called the fastest
growing
refugee crisis in europe
since the second world war
today indeed is not a day
we had in mind
in the weeks before the military
offensive began in ukraine
and despite the din of commentary and
rhetoric and prediction
humanitarian organizations went about
their business
they've been working in the donbass
region providing
one and a half million people there
with humanitarian aid a business they
have been doing
quietly and without fun fair fun fair
these past eight years
and they're doing it still today
however and whenever they can
but of course
they the humanitarian agencies also
prepared for worse to come
two weeks ago
few thought
the scenario in which we find ourselves
today
one of such intense conflict
was thinkable
it was essentially unplannable from the
humanitarian
operational perspective and yet
that humanitarian community did plan
we looked to the possible numbers
with the unhcr and iom and our ngo
partners and unicef and wfp
we estimated together who might be in
need who might be on the move
or those vulnerable people who might
need help at home
we looked at possible routes and methods
of delivery
the world food program mobilized its
considerable
logistics to get supply trains supply
chains up and running from a standing
start
we knew that this operation
would need the best of talent
and all humanitarian agencies and
including my office sent in surge staff
in the days
before that offensive began
and as the unthinkable became the
reality
the un and its humanitarian partners
started a scalable and agile adaptable
and resilient humanitarian operation
fit for the changing situation
they started it
the secretary-general at record speed
appointed amin awad
a person of the widest experience of
fast-moving operations
including in that very region
as his crisis coordinator
amin supported by oznat lubrani the
experienced resident and humanitarian
coordinator
is in ukraine
as we meet here today
in the first days of the offensive our
staff
like so many in ukraine
spent their days and nights working from
bunkers and basements
yet they managed to produce the two
robust response plans which philippe
filippo and i launched last week in
geneva
to a very generous donor response
president
do i need to describe
what we have all seen and heard on the
news
simply put millions of lives shattered
people can't stay home with shops shut
power and water cut
shells falling phones switched off
they can't find what they need even if
they have money to pay for it
and as we have seen even as the tv
cameras roll many can't flee in safety
either in this conflict
it's been 11 days of escalating violence
fear and pain
as of 6th of march
the office of the un high commissioner
for human rights reported
at least 1 207 civilian casualties
including at least 406 dead
and i guess the real figure could be
considerably higher
unhcr reports that more than 1.7 million
refugees have fled
and that figure is probably out of date
already
in 11 days
madame president humanitarian assistance
has continued
in areas where security permits
under the leadership of the crisis
coordinator and the resident and
humanitarian coordinator in country
we have new plans now of course on how
to deliver where humanitarian needs are
most acute
this includes the cities
that we have seen so much on these last
days such as mariopol kharkiv kercson
our response is being scaled up from
hubs in venezia uzarod and levive
the un and our partners and we will hear
i'm sure from kathy in a minute have
already provided food to hundreds of
thousands the world food programme is
setting up supply chain operations to
deliver immediate food and cash
assist assistance to three to five
million people inside ukraine
who
has shipped trauma care emergency
surgery commitment and other supplies
that will help that will help
in days to come thousands of people and
more supplies are on their way hcr is
providing assistance
albeit as a small scale at the moment
through a network of shops and
supermarkets in mariopol in
collaboration with ngos msf never left
training trauma surgeons providing
support
for the people in that city it's
bringing in thousands unhcr's bringing
in thousands of blankets mattresses and
other non-food items
from poland thank you to poland and
shipping them to transit centers
and we're good to hear and i look
forward to hearing a lot more about the
experience of children
from kathy from the vital work of unicef
and its partners the ukrainian red cross
has distributed humanitarian assistance
to thousands by its via its emergency
stockpiles
including hygiene and food kits warm
clothing and medicine and i would like
to take the chance here to salute the
more than 4 000
ukraine red cross volunteers across the
country used to conflict of course the
community workers also of local ngos
the truck drivers carrying basic
necessities into volatile areas these
are people all in harm's way
who have no hesitation in carrying out
their mission
madam president i see three immediate
priorities to lessen the pain and
suffering we're all watching unfold in
real time
first
the parties need to take constant care
to spare civilians and civilian homes
and infrastructure in their military
operations
this includes allowing safe passage for
civilians to leave areas of active
hostilities on a voluntary basis in the
direction they choose
all civilians whether they stay or leave
must be respected and protected
second
we need safe passage for humanitarian
supplies into areas
of active active hostilities civilians
in places like manurepal kharkiv
militopol and elsewhere
desperately need aid especially
life-saving medical supplies the kind
that have been
brought in in these past days by who
many modalities are possible but it must
take place in line with the party's
obligation under the wars of law laws of
war
and thirdly we urgently need a system of
constant communication with the parties
to the conflict and assurances to enable
the delivery of humanitarian aid and we
have seen these systems in place in
other countries of course as you know
well
a humanitarian notification system as we
term it
can support delivery of aid at the scale
needed
i have already
conveyed these three points
to the authorities of ukraine and to the
russian federation
and on the third point
thanks to the cooperation with the
russian federation
my office has sent a team to moscow to
work on better humanitarian
civil military coordination that can
allow us to scale up precisely to begin
to establish a humanitarian notification
system
this follows last friday's phone call
between the secretary general and the
minister of defense of the russian
federation sergey shoigu
un teams have held the first technical
meeting with the representatives of the
ministry of defense
i welcome cooperation by both sides
and sincerely hope to see further
progress
in the hours
excuse me in the hours ahead
madam president people are watching
as this unnecessary conflict
engulfs cities and civilians
as well as what's happening in ukraine
they have an extra sense of dread
over the impact this will have on the
wider world
i include myself in this category
i'm deeply worried about the
consequences on vulnerable people living
half a world away
food prices are spiking supplies are
uncertain
we didn't need that
either
people in the sahel in yemen the horn of
africa afghanistan madagascar and
already faced profound profound food
insecurity
record level fuel prices means life
becomes harder still
in places like lebanon
where generators keep hospitals open and
water treatment plants working
and
the extraordinary generosity which i
welcome and praise
of donors to the the launch of the
regional plan and the ukraine
humanitarian response plan
we hope that this will not divert those
donors from other pressing humanitarian
crises
this may be the latest one
but not the only one
so while we have planned we have
mobilized we have fundraised to meet the
challenge we face we have the capacity
and i think the know-how
to meet the most urgent needs in ukraine
on the basis of cooperation with the
parties but and here i would like to
stress this particular last point
make no mistake
we are unable to meet the needs of
civilians today all those points that i
have made are points in preparation and
supply in redeployment
in getting to the right place
but we're failing to meet the needs of
civilians today at this time
i hope we will not fail them tomorrow
thank you madam president
i thank mr griffith for his
briefing and i now give the floor to
miss catherine russell
excellencies and colleagues
it's my appreciation to ambassador
thomas greenfield and ambassador ferret
hoja for convening today's meeting i
would also like to thank ambassador
nussa
from the united arab emirates for
hosting this briefing during your
security council presidency
this is my first time briefing the
security council as unicef executive
director i regret that it has been made
necessary by the rapidly worsening
situation in ukraine and the
unconscionable impact the conflict is
having on ukraine's children
the past eight years of conflict in
ukraine have already inflicted profound
and lasting harm to children
with the escalation of this conflict the
immediate and very real threat to
ukraine's 7.5 million children has grown
homes schools orphanages and hospitals
have all come under attack
civilian infrastructure like water and
sanitation facilities have been hit
leaving millions without access to safe
water
for many life has moved underground as
families seek safety in shelters subways
or basements often for hours on end
women are giving birth in makeshift
maternity wards with limited medical
supplies
most stores are closed making it hard
for people to buy essential items
including basic necessities for children
like diapers and medication
and even if stores were open millions of
people are too afraid to venture outside
for food or water because of continuous
shelling and shooting
the intensification of the armed
conflict is posing severe human costs
which are increasing exponentially by
the day
as of today the office of the high
commissioner of human rights recorded
1207 civilian cash casualties in ukraine
since february 24 at least 27 children
have been killed and 42 children have
been wounded countless more have been
severely traumatized
as the fighting has now reached densely
populated areas and across the country
we expect child casualties to increase
we also expect this placement crisis to
continue growing rapidly
as of yesterday unhcr was reporting in
excess of 1.7 million refugees fleeing
to hosting countries
half of the people on the move are
children unicef is working closely with
unhcr to reach them with protection and
assistance in receiving countries i've
just returned from romania ukraine
border where thousands of women and
children traveled to escape the fighting
i met with mothers and children who had
to flee their homes at a moment's notice
they told me how it felt to leave
everything they know
behind to leave husbands fathers and
elderly loved ones not knowing when or
if they would see each other again
the children talked about being suddenly
pulled out of school of losing beloved
toys and the terrifying terrifying sound
of shelling and gunfire so many children
have been deeply traumatized
excellencies unicef and our partners are
working 24 hours a day to meet rapidly
escalating humanitarian needs in ukraine
and in neighboring countries
from trucking in safe water for drinking
and hygiene providing emergency medical
services and providing shelter and
protection for those displaced from
their homes
at present we have some 135 people
working for unicef in ukraine and we are
sending more to meet
needs in country unicef supported child
protection mobile teams are reaching
children wherever they can with
psychosocial care mental health support
and protection services
the operating environment in ukraine is
extremely complex
access constraints and rapidly changing
front lines make it more much more
difficult to deliver critical supplies
and services the safety and well-being
of our staff on the ground remains a top
priority
i also want to spotlight our local
partners and other local humanitarian
actors who continue to operate under
extremely difficult security conditions
especially those working in the donetsk
and lohan's oblast regions that have
been hard hit over the past several
weeks
i'm very glad to tell you that on sunday
unicef delivered 40 tons of medical life
saving items for children and mothers to
22 hospitals in five of the most
affected regions
this equipment included midwifery and
obstetrics kits resuscitation surgical
kits oxygen concentrators for shelters
hospitals and first aid kits for
frontline workers enough to meet the
needs of 20 000 children and their
mothers in coordination with the
ministry of health unicef is assessing
further needs and preparing other
shipments
unicef and our partners need flexible
resources and safe uninterrupted access
to rapidly scale up our efforts to meet
children's urgent needs wherever they
are
whether still in ukraine or on the move
in collaboration with unhcr we have
deployed teams to poland hungary czech
republic and the republic of slovakia
and built on our ongoing presence in
romania moldova and belarus to support
the urgent needs of children we've begun
operating blue dots
safe spaces in hosting countries at
border crossings where children are
first registered the hubs provide a
one-stop safe space for children and
their families
they offer a range of services including
places for children to play psycho
social support basic legal counseling
recreational kits and hygiene products i
visited one of these last week
staff at these hubs are also able to
identify unaccompanied and separated
children
children without parental care are at a
heightened risk of violence abuse and
exploitation
when these children are moved across
borders the risks are multiplied the
risk of trafficking also soars in
emergencies
unicef and unhcr have urged all hosting
countries to take measures to identify
and registered unaccompanied and
separated children fleeing ukraine after
allowing them access to their country
temporary foster care and other
community-based care provided through a
government system can help protect
children who have been displaced without
their families but we want to stress
that adoption should never occur during
or immediately after emergencies every
effort should be made to reunify
children with their families
inside ukraine unicef is also deeply
concerned about the safety and
well-being of the nearly one hundred
thousand children half of them with
disabilities who live in institutions
and boarding schools we have received
reports of institutions understandably
seeking to move children to safety in
neighboring countries and beyond
many of these children
have living relatives or legal guardians
all of these children have the children
have the right to be protected while we
recognize that humanitarian evacuations
may become necessary to save lives
special measures must be taken to
contact relatives and obtain consent to
move these children to safety and to
reunify them with their families when
the threat is passed
with the spread of the conflict we
should all be extremely concerned about
the risk posed to children by land mines
and explosive remnants of war even prior
to the recent escalation eastern ukraine
was one of the most mine contaminated
stretches of land in the world this
brutal reality is rapidly extending to
other parts of the country
we will continue doing everything we can
for children in ukraine we are committed
to stay and deliver but we need your
support
excellencies what is happening to
children in ukraine is a moral outreach
outrage
images of a mother and her two children
and a friend lying dead on the street
hit by a mortar as they tried to flee to
safety must shock the conscience of the
world
we must act to protect children from
this brutality
unicef calls upon the members of this
council to remind all parties of their
legal and moral obligation to protect
children and spare them from attack
we remain extremely concerned about
attacks on the civilian infrastructure
necessary to help children weather this
conflict
including schools hospitals water and
sanitation facilities and critical
energy infrastructure we call on all
parties to refrain from fighting near or
targeting these protected areas and from
cyber attacks that can disrupt critical
services for children and families we
appeal to all parties to avoid the use
of explosive weapons in populated areas
including cluster munitions which pose
the gravest risk of harm to children and
we urge all parties to protect civilians
from further harm related to
contamination from landmines and
explosive remnants of war unicef
respectfully asked this council to send
a strong message to all parties of their
obligation to ensure the safety of
humanitarian personnel and equipment and
to permit and facilitate our work this
also means ensuring that sanctions and
other restrictive measures do not impede
humanitarian action finally we have
renewed our call for an immediate
suspension of ongoing military actions
in ukraine
we need a ceasefire and adequate
guarantees to enable safe and rapid
humanitarian access to all people in
need across ukraine
this will allow critical humanitarian
assistance and protection to reach those
in need and to let families in those
most affected areas venture out to get
food and water seek medical care and
leave their homes to find safety
in closing i would like to emphasize
that unicef is a humanitarian actor
abiding by humanitarian principles over
the past eight years unicef has been
working on both sides of the line of
contact in eastern ukraine and we are
committed to providing humanitarian
assistance and protection to all
children in need across ukraine and in
neighboring countries
but this brutality must come to an end
excellencies colleagues children in
ukraine need help and protection they
need supplies and other critical support
they need access to basic social
services like health and education
they need hope for the future
but above all children in ukraine need
peace
it is the only sustainable solution
thank you for the opportunity to speak
to you today
i thank ms russell for her briefings
i now give the floor to those council
members who wish to make statements
i give the floor
to the representative of the united
states
thank you madam president
thank you executive director russell at
your first briefing uh to the council we
welcome you
uh to uh this setting and thank you also
to under secretary general griffiths
both of your briefings were
extraordinarily sobering
but we very much appreciate the work
that you do
i also want to say that we're so
appreciative and so proud and grateful
to unicef and ocha and other
humanitarian agencies staff on the
ground in ukraine
and throughout the region
we've seen the images of them
coordinating deliveries from bomb
shelters and continuing to provide
assistance to the ukrainian people
under difficult and dangerous conditions
they are a testament to the life-saving
work of the un's human un's humanitarian
agencies
and your indispensable role helping
vulnerable civilians suffering the
consequences of war
we are outraged by increased reports of
moscow's attacks harming ukrainian
civilians in its unprovoked and
unjustified war against the ukrainian
people
president putin's war of choice has
already turned
half a million children into refugees
already more than 1.7 million civilians
have fled ukraine into surrounding
countries
and this doesn't include those who have
been internally displaced
we've seen the images of elderly fleeing
a woman killed in her wheelchair
children dying in their mother's arms
and a woman being rushed bleeding to a
hospital
these are the images that we're seeing
daily
of what is happening on the ground in
ukraine
last week i had the opportunity to speak
to my counterparts from romania poland
hungary
slovakia and moldova where their
governments
international organizations and ngos
have been working non-stop to welcome
all those who are fleeing
what i heard was staggering
my polish colleague who's sitting in the
room with us today
shared that 100 refugees are crossing
into poland every minute
100 a minute
just do the math
we talked about many of the challenges
these neighboring countries are facing
and how the united states can help keep
their borders open to all those seeking
international protection including those
who may experience communication
barriers with border agents due to
disabilities or other factors
we're committed to providing support and
we know that their needs will only
increase if russia does not cease its
violence
we know this because of what we've seen
over the last week
from the reckless attack on europe's
largest nuclear power plant
to the siege of cities across ukraine
to the tragic images and alarming
reports from those who are unable to
leave ukraine to seek safety
the world is haunted by these images of
homes hospitals schools orphanages being
destroyed
demolished in front of our eyes
child cancer patients unable to receive
chemotherapy
babies delivered in basements instead of
maternity wards and hundreds of
thousands of civilians without access to
electricity for heat or drinking water
to stay alive
ukrainian cities are under siege under
relentless russian shelling
hospitals are running out of supplies
food is adrenaline
and civilian countries are mounting
while the most vulnerable group
those with disabilities the elderly
children continue to bear the brunt of
suffering
we have seen besiegement before
from leningrad to aleppo
these are tragedies of immense
proportions
the united states is closely
coordinating with the government of
ukraine
neighboring countries and international
organizations including those within the
u.n system to monitor the situation and
we will work with them to address
humanitarian needs both in ukraine and
in the region
[Music]
while we are heartened by the
international community's pledges of
over 1.5 billion dollars in humanitarian
support so far
we know that as long as russia pursues
this relentless and brutal campaign
the need for assistance will only
increase
we all need to ensure
these pledged funds are flexible and
mobilized as quickly as possible given
the escalating needs on the ground
but perhaps most important of all we
must heed the call we heard today from
the under secretary general for
humanitarian affairs
that means a sustained pause in
hostilities to allow the safe passage of
civilians who wish to leave areas of
active conflict
the safe passage of humanitarian
supplies
and the free and safe movement
of those delivering humanitarian
assistance
we need russia's firm
clear
public and unequivocal commitment to
allow and facilitate immediate
unhindered humanitarian access for
humanitarian partners in ukraine
very s
very specifically we call for the
russian federation to agree to
and honor
in good faith ukrainian proposals for
time-bound
humanitarian safe passage in specific
agreed-upon locations
we call for the establishment of a
ground-level notification system that
will facilitate the safe movement of
humanitarian convoys and flights
this is imperative for ensuring
humanitarian supplies and commodities
can be reliably transported into ukraine
to reach those most in need
i also want to note today that the
united states is increasingly concerned
about the protection of civilians in
this conflict particularly women and
girls who are vulnerable to gender-based
violence lgbtqi ukrainians as well as
ukraine's population of older adults and
people with disabilities
we also call for the protection and care
of all vulnerable children including
separated and unaccompanied children and
those in institutional care
children should never
never be involved in conflict
period
children should never be involved in
conflict
they must be protected
the humanitarian toll of president
putin's war on ukraine is mounting
children are dying people are fleeing
their homes and for what
as unicef has reported we know already
that dozens of children have been killed
in putin's war
and as we work to confirm cases we know
the actual numbers are actually far
greater
young children have also been severely
traumatized by the violence and
destruction
they've witnessed
so many things to the point that they've
stopped speaking
the physical and psychological wounds of
this war
will be long lasting
[Music]
it's clear mr putin has a plan
to
destroy and terrorize ukraine
if the last two weeks have shown us
anything
it's that the ukrainian people are not
going to give up
and many russian people themselves
including many russian soldiers do not
want this war
unfortunately mr putin doesn't seem to
be listening and we are concerned that
the world needs to be prepared
for a very long
and very difficult road ahead
the ukrainians are defending themselves
bravely and we will continue to stand
with them and support them but president
putin is clearly willing to sacrifice
the lives of thousands of russian
soldiers to achieve his personal
ambitions
we have been warning moscow for weeks
that in the end russia will be weaker
and not stronger for launching this war
this is already proving true
the question is how much devastation
president putin is willing to wreck
for this enormous mistake
we continue to call on russia to change
course withdrawals forces de-escalate
through diplomacy and we support
ukraine's call for a ceasefire
in the meantime we applaud those doing
everything in their power to alleviate
the suffering putin has unleashed on the
ukrainian people
whatever course russia's invasion may
take
we must do everything
and i stress
everything everything we can to help the
people of ukraine
keeve still stands and we stand with kev
we stand
with ukrainians thank you
i thank the representative of the united
states for her statement and i give the
floor to the representative of albania
thank you madam president
thank you executive director russell and
welcome to the council
and thank you as well uh usg griffiths
for this sobering and payful
briefing
more than that thank you for everything
you and your teams are doing in meeting
as much as you can the huge and
increasing humanitarian needs in ukraine
dear colleagues
today marks the 12th day of the
unprovoked and unjustified aggression
against ukraine
a war of choice that is becoming a war
of obsession
like in every day of this senseless war
ukraine and its brave citizens find
themselves in the well-known sickening
inevitability of every conflict
civilians are killed
children are traumatized and women are
suffering
in less than two weeks russia managed to
create out of nothing and for no reason
the fastest and largest
mass refugee crisis in europe since
world war ii
we were told that this so-called special
operation
the domestic nickname and the new
russian definition for aggression
would not target civilians
in reality
civilians are assaulted and trapped
among rubble
toddlers are sheltering in cellars and
subway tunnels
and as we saw last week
nuclear plants are on the threat of
deliberate or accidental hit
fueled by anger due to the heroic
ukrainian resistance
civilian population civilian
infrastructure residential area schools
and hospitals as we heard
everything has become a target
even diplomatic representations are not
spared as it happened today with our own
honorary consulate in kharkiv
dear colleagues
the huge humanitarian needs across the
country are multiplying by the hour
hundreds of thousands are without safe
drinking water because of damage to
system infrastructure
and many have been cut off from access
to other essential services like health
care
more than one point million people are
on the move searching for shelter and
safety including in neighboring
countries
families have been walking long
distances in freezing temperatures to
find shelter
most of them in neighboring countries
half of them are children
we upload the way poland moldova hungary
and slovakia have responded in welcoming
and sheltering hundreds of thousands of
displaced people
they must not be left alone
the escalating aggression ukraine has
been terrifying especially to children
tens of thousands of children have seen
their daily lives and routines shattered
thousands are separated from their
families in shock and desperate
for safety
this is what russia is doing
so i have some very simple direct
questions
what in the world can justify exposing
children to such extreme violence and
unbearable levels of fear and anxiety
where is the humanity of a great nation
where is the responsibility of a great
power
where are the commitments of a permanent
member of this body
does international humanitarian law have
still any meaning for russia today
the answers lie under the blood of
innocent ukrainians
dear colleagues
russia's actions are a gross violation
of geneva conventions and are classified
as war crime under the rome statute
it must be made clear that if anyone in
russia thinks that what they are doing
ukraine is a rendezvous with history
and get away with atrocities and crimes
against humanity they must think twice
there will be accountability
albania was among 38 countries to refer
ukraine to the icc prosecutor
we fully support his work to gather
proof and document crimes committed to
present them to the court
it is therefore urgent to open secure
humanitarian corridors for the safe
evacuation of civilians and for the
delivery of medicine and food
the russian side must stop ignoring the
appeals of international humanitarian
organizations
in particular the international
committee of the red cross to cease fire
in order to create safe conditions for
the departure of civilians and wounded
without discrimination on the basis of
race ethnicity nationality or migration
status differentiation between people on
any ground especially on the basis of
race or ethnicity are legally
unjustifiable and morally analytically
unacceptable
dear colleagues
there is a devastating bloody war on the
ground but there is another nasty war in
the background
the latter concerns information
we remain worried about developments
within russia itself regarding freedom
of information
with the latest measures taken by the
parliament authorities in russia have
shut down foreign broadcasters whose
work becomes impossible under the law
which criminalizes independent reporting
in the country
the last major local independent
broadcasters
tv drawers and ecomosphere radio were
shut down last week
we know from our own terrible communist
past that attacking freedom of
information in this way
is the first sign of a dictatorship
when a government is afraid of its own
people it has a fundamental problem
russian citizens have the right to know
why their country attacked its neighbor
they need to be informed about the
actions of their army against the people
of ukraine
mothers must know why their sons are
dying
and russians deserve better than doctor
propaganda
otherwise they would only hear about the
fictional ukrainian genocide in donbas
which never happened
about ukraine attacking russia which
never happened
or about russia winning the war which is
not happening
madam president
protection of civilians should remain a
top priority
yet as bombardments intensify fueled by
the anger caused by the heroic ukrainian
resistance
we are also worried about the
destruction of cultural heritage
indiscriminate bombardments have already
destroyed architectural ensembles in car
cave and risk inflicting irreparable
damage to the ukrainian cultural
heritage widely
heritage is a testimony of the past but
also a vector of peace for the future
which russia is assaulting
let me end with the cry of this woman
alexandria living in kharkiv
this was last week and i don't know
whether she is still alive
she was saying my mom my city is being
shelved but my mom won't believe me
her mom who lives in russia would
respond to her call that she heard on tv
that the russian army would never target
civilians
it's ukrainians who are killing their
own people
their colleague
12 days ago ukraine was guilty because
it exists
now they are guilty because they do not
surrender
what is tamara made of for them
we call on russia to come to census and
stop
we call on russia to hold this
aggression and go home
the world knows what they are doing
what is happening is a global air raid
siren a warning of how important
multilateralism is and how much we need
it to work and how essential it is to
make everything possible to stop this
war and make the aggressor pay for it
when one behaves like a rogue state it
should not pretend to be treated
differently
albania reaffirms its unwavering support
for the independence sovereignty and
territorial integrity of ukraine within
its international organized borders and
this position was reiterated today just
a few hours ago by a resolution adopted
by the albanian parliament
i thank you
albania
i thank the representative of albania
for his statement and i now give the
floor for the representative of the
russian federation
thank you very much madam president
we thank martin griffiths for his views
we welcome to the meeting the new
executive director of unicef catherine
russell
and thank her for her report
we wish to note
that
we've seen
the
non-bias
in ukraine's reaction to this crisis
over its last eight years of its
existence the fund didn't turn a blind
eye to the bombardments of donbass to
the territory of don yatskundagansk
and the problems for children that came
from this in terms of the humanitarian
and psychological situation we hope that
this non-biased approach will continue
in the future
we think that unicef's views should be
based on
reliable tried and tested information
we welcome the reflection in the
humanitarian plan of the dangerous fact
of the mass proliferation on ukrainian
territory of small arms and light
weapons
many of which have fallen into the hands
of radical elements
including those who have been
deliberately freed from prison
the consequences of this irresponsible
step by voladimizalensky who gave the
order are already clear
the number of civilian victims
among civilians from the hands of the
radicals is increasing day by day first
and foremost in kiev we have been
drawing attention to this for a long
time
we call on all colleagues in the
security council to strictly keep in
today's meeting to the humanitarian
context of the situation in ukraine
we've already had the opportunity to
exchange political views on what's
happening and it's clear that our views
diverge from yours
and that you continue
to rely on the opinion of ukrainian
politicians and also doubtful or openly
mendacious material from social networks
in presenting the course and aims of our
special operation in ukraine in an
unfavorable light we once again wish to
we agree with the representative of
albania that there is an information war
going on more likely a disinformation
war and we would say that in the west in
the free world
where russian information resources are
being turned off and where
any information which contradicts your
version of events is not allowed to be
broadcast
the permanent representative of the
united states today accused us
of not complying with our commitments
to create safe humanitarian corridors
let's go down into this
we once again wish to emphasize that
safety for civilians in ukraine is not a
problem for for russian
because we're not bombarding them but
rather ukrainian radicals and neo-nazis
who are holding hostage whole towns and
cities and are making use of citizens as
a
as a human shield not allowing them to
leave cities despite the fact that there
are humanitarian corridors and that
russian units have declared a ceasefire
there are a panoply of examples of this
thus on the fourth of march the ministry
of defense of russia and the
deputy prime minister of ukraine arena
versus agreed parameters for
humanitarian corridors from mariopol to
zaparagia
they were supposed to be opened up at 10
in the morning on the 5th of march
at kiev's request
the
representatives of the international red
cross were invited to the areas where
these corridors are being opened our
cybers ready to provide wholehearted
assistance in guaranteeing safety for
the evacuation of these people
we informed the un secretariat of all of
this in timely fashion
however
the radicals in mario paul
violated this agreement
as is clear from a conversation a radio
conversation that was intercepted
between two commanders of the
nationalist battalion azov that is in
vulner
the radicals there were told to shoot at
the legs of those who had heading who
were heading for the humanitarian
corridors those who risked life and limb
to try and leave mario paul when they
reached the checkpoints to and to exit
the city were shot on site by ukrainian
nazis there's a great deal of video
evidence of this
and those who are ready to the
humanitarians who are trying to offer
assistance aren't able to get there
and to prevent the catastrophe that is
developing in the town
the critical situation for people in
other regions of the country is if they
are also blockaded by nationalist
battalions we note that ukrainian
radicals day by day are showing their
true face more clearly
the local civil local
inhabitants have said that they
forced out the staff of a maternity
clinic and then put a firing site in
that clinic they also completely
destroyed one of the nursery schools in
the city
in addition
we state officially that ukrainian
authorities have categorically refused
to
cooperate on evacuating people from
harkov or sumi
considering the catastrophic
humanitarian situation and it's
worsening in kiev harcourt and mariupol
and also the
personal request of president emmanuel
macron to president putin the russian
armed forces stated that from the 10th
of from 10 a.m on the 7th of october 7th
of march 2022 there will be a ceasefire
and they will open humanitarian
corridors from kiev mariupol and sumi
towards russian territory
for those who wish to evacuate through
that
logistically viable route but also
towards ukrainian territory
this information was conveyed the
evening before to kiev to the
specialized agencies of the un to the
osce the icrc and other international
organizations through all available
information resources
including the media
an official answer from kiev was
received only today at 7 10 a.m
at moscow
but the open humanitarian corridors
towards the russian federation were
ignored
this subject was raised in her official
statement by the ukrainian deputy prime
minister very shock who called the
proposal to open humanitarian corridors
towards russia and i quote absurd and
unacceptable end quote
it is clear to us that the kiev regime
is making use of all available and
unavailable methods to wholeheartedly
stop the exit of those citizens who wish
to leave to
wish to go to russia because they're
scared but once these people are free
they will tell the truth about the
actions of ukrainian radicals
as is being done by those people who
have been able to get out away from
these radicals we're talking here about
threats intimidation blackmail physical
violence and also shooting on site
directed at citizens and also foreigners
by well of illustration just one
statement from the mayor of sumi
alexandre lisenko this was made today
together with the commander of the
national battalion and i quote
there will not be any green corridors
no civilians will leave to russia and
those who try to
will be shot dead
end of quote
in their statements on the impossibility
of evacuating ukrainian citizens towards
russia ukrainian officials have ignored
the fact that
there were already ukrainian refugees in
russia
from the area of the special military
operation more than 168 000 people have
been evacuated to russia including 43
469 children
and in the last 24 hours
550 people including 740 children
the russian border has been crossed by
19 256 private vehicles
and in the last 24 hours by 900 of them
we are also establishing temporary
accommodation points these are all ready
for individual work with
citizens or rather civilians arriving
from ukraine
unfortunately the issue of the
evacuation of the population from other
regions is also being politicized as is
the issue of humanitarian assistance
in particular the requests of the
ukrainian party look absurd these are
the requests made to us
less than three hours before the opening
of humanitarian corridors asking us to
guarantee the evacuation from a number
of settlements that are under the
control of the russian armed forces
in this none of the inhabitants of these
of these
inhabited places had what i said they
wanted to evacuate people were simply
living in their houses and they're not
threatened by anything
in parallel we were asked to
organize the evacuation of citizens from
a number of cities which for the time
being are under the control of the
nationalist battalions
and of course we were also asked to
provide alleged humanitarian goods from
ukraine to military and bergens in the
zaparoj region and in her son this also
looks cynical towards the inhabitants of
these cities because at the moment these
regions are under the full control of
the russian armed forces
and their populations are continuing to
live peacefully and have everything that
they need including humanitarian
assistance from russia
which has arrived to different regions
of ukraine 500 000 tons of it madam
president we are also particularly
concerned that the ukrainian radicals
are continuing to hold hostage
as human shields more than 1500
foreigners in a range of cities we are
working around the clock with
the relevant diplomatic agencies on this
issue
but foreigners are having very severe
problems when trying to cross the border
when they're trying to leave towards
europe we're talking here about
we're talking here about citizens from a
range of different countries including
african countries
we've also we also draw your attention
to a public statement by the senegalese
representative of the african union on
this issue we are shocked by news of the
inhumane attacks by nationalists on
student accommodation which has among
other things caused the death of indian
students
with regard to the safety of u.n
personnel in ukraine and for us this is
one of the priorities
currently the russian troops are
guaranteeing have guaranteed the exit
from kiev of 180 u.n personnel
when the need with necessary this
support will continue we are in constant
contact with the ukraine with the un
secretariat
we take a wholeheartedly responsible
approach to resolving the humanitarian
issues that ukrainian citizens are
facing on the 2nd of march on the base
of the national defense management
center there was an inter-agency
coordination staff created for
humanitarian response in connection with
the special operation carried out in
ukraine this is working around the clock
the
staff include the authorized
representatives of all of the federal
bodies of the executive state
corporations and entities of the russian
federation the main objective of the
staff is to guarantee multi-faceted
humanitarian assistance to the ukrainian
population in the controlled regions and
also in donetsk and luganza people's
republics also guaranteeing the safe
evacuation of peaceful city of civilians
from
in ukraine and other countries
madam president i also have to mention
another aspect the deployment of heavy
weaponry including anti-aircraft defense
systems mobile rocket launch systems
bombardment artillery in heavily
populated areas this is not a question
of isolated incidents but it's become a
rule for ukrainian nationalist
battalions the attempts of civilians to
protest and to request that this
weaponry be
removed have brutally been stopped with
threats of the use of weapons
the similar cowardice on the part of the
combatants using the civilian population
as hostages is not just deeply immoral
but also violates the norms of
international humanitarian law
including articles 57 and 58 of the
first additional protocol to the geneva
convention of 1949. furthermore in a
number of cities in particular in odessa
it has been recorded that weaponry has
been placed near or inside objects of
cultural heritage in violation of
article 53 of this additional protocol
the break-off in the evacuation of the
civilians from humanity using
humanitarian corridors is a violation of
article 75 of the additional protocol
and the footage published on social
networks of torture and abuse of russian
troops who are being imprisoned is a
violation of article 14 of the geneva
convention of 1949 which guarantees
respect for the person and the dignity
of troops under any circumstances
colleagues i encourage you to make the
correct approach correct um
correct appraisal of all of these
activities we also expect the same from
the un's leadership otherwise you will
be encouraging ukrainian radicals and
neo-nazis to new crimes madam president
in conclusion i wish to once again
firmly encourage our western colleagues
to convince the ukrainian leadership to
think finally about the safety of the
ukrainian and foreign citizens held
hostage by radicals and to join in the
work to open and to guarantee the safety
of humanitarian corridors
if of course you still have
any
ways to influence the nationalists
we have greater and greater doubts about
that we for our part are ready to do
such work thank you very much
and i'd first like to thank the
unicef executive director catherine
russell welcome her to the chamber and
thank her and under secretary general
griffiths for their briefings today
your messages were really really stark
but we need to hear them
the international community needs to
hear the facts
we commend the vital work of all
humanitarians in ukraine
and today on the eve of international
women's day i salute the courage of all
women working on the grand in ukraine to
save lives
the safety and security of all those
brave individuals must be insured
madam president one of the youngest
fleeing over the weekend was a
two-month-old boy called andre
who crossed the border from ukraine into
poland
as is aunt valentina comforted andre and
his mother she told unhcr i never
thought i would have to leave my home
that i would have to flee just to save
my life
the russian federation's invasion of
ukraine has now created nothing short of
a humanitarian catastrophe
as a brutal war is waged we are seeing
little to no regard for the safety of
civilians
andrea and valentina represent just two
of the 1.7 million people who have
become refugees in less than two weeks
we gathered some things and fled
valentina said she had reason to
we now know that something in the order
of 12 million people are in need of
assistance
thousands have been killed and injured
the human cost mounting by the day
a humanitarian catastrophe simply of
tragic proportion
in densely populated cities in villages
and towns ukrainian civilians are forced
to shelter for safety in underground car
parks and metro stations
their daily lives upended
everything on hold terrorized
all the while the use of explosive
weapons destroy their homes
and the civilian infrastructure they
rely on for survival
we are hearing reports hourly of
multiple attacks on medical facilities
including maternity and children's
hospitals even oncology clinics
all protected under international
humanitarian law
we have looked on in horror as attempts
to evacuate the estimated two hundred
thousand people from mariopol have
failed
the icrc has been clear
whatever is agreed or not agreed on
humanitarian corridors or other measures
civilians and civilian infrastructure
must be protected
this applies both to those who choose to
leave
and to those who choose to remain
that's a core obligation under
international humanitarian law
each chilling violation of international
law
evokes the darkest days of europe's past
president the humanitarian consequences
of damage to civilian infrastructure is
not abstract
it means interrupted supplies of
electricity critical for the continuing
functioning of hospitals and essential
services
it means heating homes
it means enabling parents
cook to feed their children
the children's hospital where valentina
worked as a volunteer was hit by
artillery at the beginning of the
invasion
as she looked at her nephew she recalled
the children she saw killed in that
attack
she says simply they were so small
ireland calls on the russian federation
to uphold its international obligations
that includes protecting civilian health
care facilities and protecting medical
and humanitarian personnel
all parties must also facilitate safe
passage and unhindered delivery of
humanitarian assistance
including medical and food supplies to
those in need
a notification system and emergency
helpline should be established to
facilitate delivery of humanitarian aid
ireland reiterates our call at last
friday's meeting
for the immediate cessation of military
activity by russia against and at
ukraine's nuclear facilities in order to
avert nuclear disaster and the
subsequent humanitarian consequences
we note that over the weekend the iaea
expressed grave concern at the situation
at their zaparisia planet
president as ms russell so clearly set
out for us today
the women and children of ukraine are in
the midst of a desperate protection
crisis
the terror of war
and the trauma of family separation will
have lifelong effects on thousands of
ukrainian children
they will be marked forever by these
days
as in all conflicts around the world
women and girls are especially
vulnerable to the abhorrent scourge of
sexual violence sexual exploitation and
abuse
all women and girls in ukraine must be
protected from rape and social and
sexual violence
we will work to ensure that there will
be no place to hide from accountability
for anyone who perpetrates crimes
against them
president in the face of the massive
exodus of refugees from ukraine we once
again commend our eu partners and
moldova for their continued generosity
and solidarity
they are welcoming vulnerable people
seeking to leave ukraine without
discrimination we appeal to all
countries in the region to keep their
borders open to all those seeking safety
and protection
ireland is fully committed to supporting
the humanitarian response both
domestically and in the region
the humanitarian impact of this war
will be felt not just on the european
continent it will affect the food
security situation in countries heavily
reliant on ukrainian agricultural
products
in africa in asia and in the middle east
reminding us at this table once again
of the inherent links between conflict
and hunger
president
ireland once again urges the russian
federation to immediately cease
hostilities
unconditionally withdraw its forces from
the entire territory of ukraine and to
refrain from further threat
of force or use of any kind of force
against ukraine or any other member
state
andre and his family speak to the human
face of this reprehensible conflict
before any more lives are ruined or lost
to this war
before more children die
before more families are separated
before it's too late we plead one more
time with the russian federation to
choose dialogue and diplomacy over bombs
and bullets
thank you madam chair
i thank the representative of ireland
for their statement i now give the floor
to the representative of the united
kingdom thank you madam president
and may i start by thanking to
martin griffiths and kathy russell for
their sobering briefings
i also want to add my thanks and
appreciation for the work of your
organizations the courage of your staff
and the integrity of your reporting
madam president
martin kathy and colleagues have already
described
in sobering detail the humanitarian
crisis in ukraine
1.7 million refugees
1.7 million
individual lives destroyed
and the un expects this to rise to four
million in the coming weeks
we've seen the devastation caused by
russian missiles and bombardment
including reports of cluster munitions
in russian cities
in ukrainian cities i'm sorry
apartment blocks torn apart
hospitals schools in ruins
people left without electricity food
water and shelter
we can't turn the clock back
russia's invasion has been met with
fierce resistance by the ukrainian
people
in response
president putin is directing a campaign
of violence and cruelty against
civilians
but let me be clear
we will hold russia to account
for its actions and we will investigate
thoroughly
allegations of war crimes and violations
of international law
madam president
in response to this tragedy
the uk prime minister today announced a
further 130 million dollars of aid which
brings to a total the uk's support for
ukraine to 520
million dollars
in addition
individual members of the british public
have given over
130 million
this is intended to help ukrainians in
need and support neighbouring countries
receive refugees
but as i've said before
what the ukrainian people really need
is an end to this invasion
so we appeal to russia
to end their war
before they bring even more tragedy to
the ukraine
and even more shame on their own nation
vasculia alexavic
the great russian writer alexander
solzhenitsyn wrote
man is given not only one life
but also
a conscience
i know that you've spoken under
instructions today
but i ask you to report faithfully back
to moscow
what you have heard today
the urgency of this council's calls for
peace i thank you
i thank the representative of the united
kingdom for their statement i now give
the floor to the representative of
mexico gracias senora president thank
you madam president
i wish
executive
director russell and under secretary
griffiths for their briefings
as they have informed us
the humanitarian situation in ukraine
11 days
the challenge is enormous boys
which will continue to increase
there is approximately 1 million uh
internally displaced people and
a lot more who should be evacuated
but have not yet been able to leave
and
the majority as we have heard are women
and children high school
other exacerbating factors have risen in
recent days which we also have heard
about such as
the critical conditions of access to
water
and food
in cities under seeds
sustained
cause of her
unrestricted safe access for all
humanitarian
workers in ukraine must be guaranteed
as well as in all neighboring countries
in accordance with international
humanitarian
the provisions of resolution 2573
must be complied with
when it comes to the protection of
civilians
the goods needed for their survival
and the essential infrastructure for the
delivery of humanitarian assistance
we also recall that in the
aforementioned resolution
the security council
was clear when it required that all
parties swarmed conflicts
establish a humanitarian pause to
facilitate the safe
and restricted and sustained delivery
of the assistance
and
under any circumstances is incarcerated
they have a devastating impact on the
civilian population
especially after the conflict is over
we call for a sub to the use of these
missions in ukraine recall on those
states that that have not already done
so to join the convention on munitions
second
the direct impact that the conflict has
on the most vulnerable must be dealt
with urgently
these
in this mass exodus that is taking place
we are particularly concerned at the
situation
of unaccompanied miners
ongoing monitoring mechanisms to have a
gender focus and take into account the
situation of children
and for this reason we recognize and
support the participation of universes
the establishment of an immediate
humanitarian pause
is essential to guarantee the access of
humanitarian workers as well as the
establishment of routes
attacks on those seeking refugees
must include the provision of mental
health and psychosocial support services
security council to adopt a resolution
which is a broadly humanitarian in
nature
and will deal
with the points that were discussed at
this meeting
it is urgent for the council
to resume its role as the main body
responsible for international peace and
and the security consultations
will serve to advance dialogue and make
it possible to bring positions closer
together and reach agreements with only
one goal in mind
to help those who urgently need
humanitarian assistance thank you very
much
i thank the representative of mexico for
their statement i now give the floor to
the representative
what is happening before our eyes is a
true humanitarian tragedy
the russian aggression
is killing uh
civilians including children every day
essential civilian infrastructures are
being destroyed hospitals and schools
are attacked the city of mario is under
siege depriving its 450 000 inhabitants
of water food heating and electricity
already 1.7
million millions
are refugees
and this is just the beginning
france hails the solidarity
richer european states particularly
poland
hungary romania slovakia and moldova
have demonstrated in europe
france and its european union partners
stand firmly beside the ukraine
the european union has announced 590
million euros of humanitarian assistance
france also does its part we have
announced 100 million euro and already
sent over 100
tons of humanitarian aid
the priority
is an immediate cessation of the
facilities and the full respect
of international humanitarian law
this is the reason for the commitment of
president macron
it is also the message
that all peoples of the world are
ascending
as was shown during the demonstrations
for peace during the weekend
more and more russians also express
their opposition to a war they do not
want despite the attempts to muzzle them
it is essential to protect civilians
including children and humanitarian
personnel
as well as civilian infrastructure
the permanent
[Music]
for this to president macron
let me uh cycle what president macron
said a few hours ago humanitarian
corridors let us be clear
are a possibility
of allowing
men and women to leave
russia
is advocating humanitarian corridors
towards russia
i don't uh know of too many ukrainians
who wish to
seek refuge in russia this is hypocrisy
this is why france and mexico are
working on a resolution calling for an
immediate cessation of facilities in the
full respect of international
humanitarian law
as mr griffiths and ms russell suggested
this council must take its full
responsibility and put an end to this
tragedy
it must be possible
for people who are trying to flee
ukraine to do so safely and without
obstruction
ukraine has taken made commitments in uh
on this front
the protection of civilians and
humanitarian access must be guaranteed
throughout their territory
both for the civilians who can leave and
those who remain behind
in presence
we call on russia to act in accordance
with the charter of the united nations
and respect humanitarian and respect
international law including
international humanitarian law and human
allegations of crimes which must not go
and punish if they are proven this is
why france supports the international
criminal court and the commissioner
inquiry
created by the human rights council
france hails the courage
shown by the people of ukraine
within the united nations and in every
international body france will continue
to mobilize with its partners to support
ukraine and the ukrainian people thank
you
i thank the representative of france for
their statement i now give the floor to
the representative of india
thank you madam president
i join others in thanking under
secretary general martin griffiths
and unicef executive director catherine
russell for their briefings
the worsening situation in ukraine and
ensuing humanitarian crisis
deserve our immediate and urgent
attention
as per the u.n estimates more than 1.5
million refugees have sought shelter in
neighboring countries of ukraine over
the last 11 days
this has led to a pressing humanitarian
crisis that needs to be addressed
expeditiously
numerous civilian lives have been lost
so far
which also includes a young indian
student
india mourns his death
and we convey our deepest condolences to
his family
just as we mourn the loss of each and
every civilian life in the conflict
india has been consistent in calling for
an immediate end to all hostilities
our prime minister once again spoke to
the leadership of both sides today
and reiterated our call for immediate
ceasefire and the need for both parties
to return to the path of dialogue and
diplomacy
we have also reiterated our urgent
demand for safe and uninterrupted
passage for all innocent civilians
including indian nationals remaining in
ukraine
we are deeply concerned that despite our
repeated urgings to both sides
the safe corridor for our students
stranded in sumi did not materialize
we have managed to facilitate the safe
return of over 20 000 indians from
ukraine
we have also assisted nationals from
other countries who approached us in
their return to their respective
countries
and we will remain open to doing so in
the coming days
more than 80 evacuation flights have
been crisscrossing the skies to bring
them home
we are appreciative of the assistance
rendered by the authorities of ukraine
and its neighboring countries in
facilitating their return
we note the joint launch of the flash
appeal and the regional refugee response
plan by the secretary general in ukraine
we hope the international community will
respond positively to the humanitarian
needs
on its part india has already sent seven
tranches of human supply human
humanitarian supplies to ukraine and its
neighboring countries
these include medicines medical
equipment tents protective eye gear
water storage tanks solar lamps amongst
other leaf material
we are in the process of identifying
other such requirements and sending more
supplies
allow me to underscore that it is
important
that humanitarian action is always
guided by the principles of humanitarian
assistance humanity neutrality
impartiality and independence
these should not be politicized i thank
you madam president
i thank the representative of india for
their statement and give the floor to
the representative of gabon
thank you very much madam president
i thank the under secretary-general mr
martin griffiths
and the executive director of unicef
catherine russell
for their very informative briefings
we take note of the nomination of mr
amin
as the u.n coordinator
for the crisis in ukraine
we are today having the second meeting
on the humanitarian situation there
which gives us information about the
situation on the ground and takes
account of the fact that
in an armed conflict the situation
cannot only develop very quickly
but the context can
alter our forecasts or our judgment of
the security situation in ukraine
deteriorates
fighting caused significant loss of
human life
and almost a million people had to leave
ukrainian territory to seek refuge in
neighboring countries
there was massive displacement of people
in particularly difficult cold
conditions these people were therefore
exposed to
urgent needs for food water
and other basic products
damage and destruction of civilian
infrastructure in the combat zones
and those affected by airstrikes and
bombing
are such that they prevent the
population from accessing
water food healthcare and other basic
services
who are in danger
my country
maintains its solidarity with the
population that is suffering and with
all the people who are facing the
consequences of this war and invites the
parties to create
safe unrestricted paths out of ukrainian
territory we call on the warring
factions to facilitate
the quick safe and unimpeded access of
humanitarian aid to the people who need
it
we call for protection for civilians
including humanitarian personnel and
vulnerable people in particular women
older people people with disabilities
and children
in line with the geneva convention
we welcome the important
multi-faceted action from the
international community which is
reflected in the donations in kind and
in financing as well as bilateral and
multilateral partnerships including from
the world bank and the imf
from the beginning of the crisis they
have activated their rapid financing
mechanisms and have promised three
billion dollars
some 550 million
of which in the very short term to
support
ukraine
this is
a support
there's also the support from the united
nations
we also express our appreciation
for the spirit and the generosity of the
country's neighboring ukraine
they have demonstrated exemplary
altruism in hosting refugees fleeing the
fighting
here
i would like to recall the humanity of
everyone
and appeal to that so that the same
reception is offered to all people who
are suffering regardless of race
and this includes nationals from africa
and african students
whose distress is no less in this
situation of confusion and terror we
call for their dignity to be respected
and for equal treatment of all people
who are suffering
indeed information is coming to us from
different sources
and time and again
it tells us that there is discrimination
and that african students are kept in
risky areas this is a concerning
situation and a morally unsustainable
one that must be vigorously denounced
madam president my country calls on the
warring factions to respect the
provisions
of international humanitarian law in
particular the geneva convention of 1949
and its additional protocols
to guarantee the respect and protection
for all medical personnel and
humanitarian workers
welcomes the establishment of
humanitarian corridors for civilians to
leave combat zones and calls on the
parties of the conflict to do all
to achieve an immediate ceasefire
i wish to reiterate the position that
gabon clearly expressed in the general
assembly namely that this situation
cannot end
without an immediate and a lasting
solution being found to end the fight
this would entail all of the parties
committing to negotiations in good faith
with the firm will to end the conflict
and to remove all the deep-rooted causes
of it
in conclusion i call on the members of
this council to take every
possibility that diplomacy offers us to
find a negotiated settlement and to
prevent an escalation of hostilities
in african culture
when two people from the same village
come to blows
it falls to their relatives their
neighbors and their friends to arbitrate
and to make an investment in finding
peace experience is often found or shown
that the
earlier friends and loved ones get
involved the earlier
calm returns
whenever the
people around the two
who are having a disagreement take sides
it makes the situation worse
of course when once calm is
re-established it is always possible to
establish who is responsible in holistic
fashion calmly
and it is in line with this bantu wisdom
from africa that i wish to reiterate to
all of the parties our call for an
immediate ceasefire and for
de-escalation i thank you madam
president
i thank the representative of gabon for
his statement i give the floor to the
representative of brazil
thank you
madam president
let me thank let me thank you for
convening this meeting and express my
appreciation
for usg griffis and executive direct
russell for their briefings
and their efforts in minimizing the
human suffering in this tragic conflict
brazil iterates
its grave concern with the humanitarian
situation arising from the ongoing
conflict in ukraine
first and foremost
we urge
all parties to establish a ceasefire and
engage in negotiations
the current situation can only bring
more suffering and losses
especially in ukraine
but potentially to the whole region
while hostilities continue
we call on our parties to fully respect
international humanitarian law
including when resorting to new military
technologies and cyber means
parties must always uphold the
principles of distinction
proportionality
precaution and humanity
brazil urges the parties to continue to
establish humanitarian pauses and to
create humanitarian corridors
we echo nonetheless
the icrc's concerns regarding the need
to respect international humanitarian
rules both for those who choose to leave
and for those who remain
the rules of war
are not optional
we insist on our call for safe timely
and unimpeded access for humanitarian
assistance to those in need
particularly the most vulnerable
we remind the plea
echoed by many member states for
neighboring countries to keep borders
open to refugees
without any kind of
discrimination
brazil reiterates its gratitude and
solidarity to poland slovakia hungary
moldova romania and others who are
facilitating the exit and reception of
refugees
madam president when the lines between
combatants and civilians become blurred
we risk seeing a rise in civilian
casualties especially in armed conflicts
fought in urban areas
when explosive
weapons are used in these contexts
in the worst cases
children may suffer the dire
consequences of armed conflicts
children in ukraine must be protected
from the dangers of war
and under no circumstances should be
recruited
used or allowed to join any military
activity or take any direct partner
hostilities
attacks against civilian infrastructures
especially schools and medical
facilities as well as water and
sanitation system must be avoided
parties must respect the optional
protocol to the convention on the rights
of the child and in its entirety
furthermore
no additional hardship should be imposed
over the affected populations and
vulnerable groups through broad economic
sanctions
children forced to free their homes to
ensure their own survival are especially
vulnerable
the increasing number of internally
displaced children in ukraine and
refugee children in neighborhood
countries
will require
support from the international community
from our side
following the swift establishment of a
humanitarian visa policy for those
fleeing the conflict
which entered into force on march 3rd
brazilian embassies in bratislava
bucharest budapest plague and the warsaw
have started to grant special visas for
displaced ukrainians and stateless
persons for humanitarian reception
purposes
madam president
a few days ago the general assembly sent
a political message
urging immediate peaceful resolution of
the conflict
this is a strong call of the
international community for peace
now the security council must place
spark and genuinely contribute for a
peaceful solution to these crisis
garnering consensus in this council
around basic humanitarian messages is
imperative
we must work collectively to widen
humanitarian corridors and the system
and to open
also the path for dialogue and diplomacy
guided by international law and the
principles of the un charter i thank you
i thank the representative of brazil
and i give the floor to the
representative of kenya
thank you madam president
i wish to thank
usg martin griffin
and executive director
catherine russell for their briefings
and i thank you for your work
i also welcome the participation
of the distinguished family
representative of ukraine
madam president
the rapidly deteriorating humanitarian
situation in ukraine is gravely
concerning
kenya offers its condolences
to the families who have lost loved ones
to the conflict in the last few days
kenya also commenced ukraine's neighbors
for opening their borders to refugees of
multiple nationalities
we ask them to ensure that the
protection
sought are offered with no
discrimination
on on the basis and particularly in
regard to race
or religion
madam president
we are disturbed by the reported
widespread damage to civilian objects
and infrastructure
kenya draws to the attention of the
parties the need for them to comply with
security council resolution 2573
on protection of objects indispensable
to the survival
of the civilian population that was
adopted by this council in
2021 madam president
ukraine
is a major producer of agricultural
products
that are key to assuring food security
the humanitarian impact of this conflict
will be fell far beyond ukraine because
of the shock to the global food
supply
indeed
the closure of its spots as a result of
the conflict
not to mention the destruction of
infrastructure
is is going to result
in fuel grain and fertilizer exports
the resulting shark prices increase are
likely to plant multiple countries into
food insecurity and as a result possible
political turmoil
in addition to ukraine's
key place in global food supply system
being impacted by the conflict the world
will also suffer greatly from the
unilateral and regional sanctions
against the russian federation
we have previously asked that
humanitarian and legal consideration
be given to the impact on the russian
people of these sanctions
now we must add our concern for the many
including in our in our own country who
will suffer
all over the world
while the sanctions are aimed at
responding to the inexcusable armed
bridge of ukraine's sovereignty and
territorial integrity by the russian
federation
they will end up
harming not only the innocent in russia
but also millions around the world
particularly in the global south in this
regard
i have two questions
for usg grievance
first
would you make public your assessments
on the impact of the armed conflict in
ukraine and the sanctions against the
russian federation on the humanitarian
situation in other countries
particularly in regard to food
security
second
what are the preventive actions
that can be taken by the un and the
security council to ensure that the
shock to the global food supply system
does not translate to new crisis
i wish to welcome the joint commitment
by ukraine and russian federation to
establish humanitarian corridors for the
safe passage of civilians and
humanitarian supplies
however
during this past weekend
the humanitarian corridors
have not have failed
we hope that the humanitarian corridors
particularly from sumi will be open to
all foreign nationals
and civilians tomorrow
civilians and foreign nationals are not
party to the conflict and must be
protected at all times
they are not and must not be a target we
strongly urge both parties
to ensure
their safe passage
we commend the united nations and its
partner agencies for their continued
efforts to provide humanitarian
assistance
in particular we welcome the
identification of four humanitarian hubs
in leve
phoenicia
usher road
and genevese
ultimately madam president the only way
out of this crisis is for a ceasefire
and dialogue to protect ukrainian
sovereignty and shape a stable european
security order i close by reiterating
kenya's recognition of the sovereignty
territorial integrity and political
independence of ukraine i thank you
i thank the representative of kenya for
a statement and i give the floor to the
representative of ghana
thank you madam president
i'd like to thank you for convening
today's session i would also like to
express my delegation's appreciation to
the unicef executive director miss
catherine russell for highlighting the
impact that the conflict has had on
children in ukraine
let me also thank under secretary
general martin griffiths for the updated
situational report on the humanitarian
crisis in ukraine
ghana is alarmed at the exponentially
high levels of the humanitarian crisis
in ukraine since this council's first
consideration of the mata on february 28
this year
at the time it was reported that about a
hundred thousand people were displaced
as some 500 000 more attempted to flee
from shelling of heavy artillery
missiles and airstrikes in the cities
today and only a week later nearly 1200
casualties have been recorded since the
start of the conflict 1.7 million people
have fled the cities of ukraine to
neighboring countries and some 160 000
have been internally displaced
what remains unchanged however are the
principles and the responsibility to
ensure the protection of all persons
suffering under the weight of the region
conflict in ukraine
we must therefore uphold the legitimacy
of the international norms of the geneva
conventions and the additional protocols
that require of conflicting parties a
duty to preserve the sanctity of human
life by taking necessary precautions to
spare the lives of civilians and avoid
the destruction of civilian
infrastructure during the time of war
all member states
are duty-bound to comply with their
international law obligations
international humanitarian law and human
rights law
failure to do so constitutes serious
violations which cannot and must not be
ignored
it is regrettable that the agreement
reached between the two sites for the
creation of humanitarian corridors for
safe evacuations and the safe passage of
food and medicines did not hold
we joined other members of this council
in reiterating the call for a
humanitarian post to allow the
evacuation of civilians especially in
the cities of mariapool and kharkev
where intense military operations are
ongoing we call for the immediate
cessation of hostilities in residential
and civilian populated areas
it is also vital that agreements are
reached to allow windows of silence that
will enable the safe and unhindered
passage of humanitarian convoys to all
areas where civilians remain in need of
water food and medical care
ghana feather supports the united
nations ask for the urgent establishment
of a notification system and an
emergency hotline with both the russian
federation and the ukrainian government
to facilitate the delivery of
humanitarian aid and life-saving
supplies
moreover we are compelled to reiterate
the absolute importance for the parties
to steer away the military hostilities
from all nuclear installations in
ukraine to avoid the risk of a nuclear
disaster we urge the iaea to continue to
monitor activities within ukraine's
nuclear program and operationalize
preventive mechanisms to avoid any
accidental occurrences
we take note of the complex environment
within which the humanitarian agencies
are operating and commend them for their
commitment we also acknowledge those
member states and international
institutions which have contributed to
the humanitarian fund required to ensure
adequate humanitarian response
we are disheartened by the trauma and
the suffering that children in ukraine
are experiencing during this period
these are the succeeding generations we
pledge to save from the schedule of war
we commend unicef for its active
engagement in the humanitarian
operations and encourage the
humanitarian agencies in their effort to
address the peculiar vulnerabilities of
children as well as the women the aged
and persons with disabilities and i'm
president i wish to take this
opportunity to commend the neighboring
countries of ukraine and other european
countries who have opened their borders
to offer refuge to persons fleeing the
conflict we continue to prevail on them
in their efforts to be guided by the
principles of humanity and neutrality
impartiality and independence in closing
madam president i must re-echo the call
upon the russian federation to end the
aggression against the internationally
recognized borders of ukraine and
withdraw its military forces we firmly
believe that military options will not
deliver the mutual demands of security
between russia and federation and
ukraine
as the humanitarian situation in ukraine
westerns economic ramifications are
already being felt globally we hope that
this council will take a unified path to
support efforts to resolve the conflict
through diplomacy and dialogue i thank
you
i thank the representative of ghana for
her statement and i give the floor to
the representative of norway
thank you president
let me begin by thanking the briefers
for their sobering account on the
humanitarian situation in ukraine
particularly for outlining the
terrifying ordeal many children are
facing
we are seriously concerned by the
staggering numbers of civil civilian
casualties in ukraine
children have been killed and wounded
children have lost their homes
let me underline that russia and russia
alone bears the sole responsibility for
this humanitarian crisis
the russian aggression agreement against
ukraine must stop now
troops must be withdrawn immediately
civilians including children
and civilian infrastructure must be
protected in accordance with
international humanitarian law we are
deeply concerned by the reported use of
cluster munition by russian forces in
ukraine these are inherently
indiscriminate weapons they continue to
kill and en
injure children long after conflict end
children are traumatized as they seek
shelter from the bombing and shelling
forced to flee across ukraine and across
borders
putting them at risk of sexual and
gender-based violence
we are deeply concerned about
unaccompanied children separated from
their families
every effort must be made to restore
family links and trace missing persons
humanitarian organizations must give
priority to the assistance and
protection of children affected by
conflict including the need for mental
health and psychosocial support
president russia's warfare in europe
urban and populated areas and the use of
heavy explosive weapons is causing
terrible long-term harm on civilians and
caused the most severe physical harm to
children killing and maiming them with
attacks on hospitals water processing
plants food system and other civilian
infrastructure children are being
deprived of services essential for their
life and health the fighting around
nuclear plants endangers the health and
safety of today's children and those of
future generation in ukraine and beyond
and schools are under attack
these attacks represent a clear
violation of a resolution 2601
on the on the protection of education in
armed conflict which this council
unanimously adopted only a few months
ago
we call on the russian federation to
respect the civilian characters of
schools and educational facilities in
accordance with international
humanitarian law
president we stand behind and support
ocha's call today for concrete steps to
be taken to ensure protection of
civilians and humanitarian access
we call on the parties to the conflict
to comply with their obligation under
international humanitarian law to allow
and facilitate safe rapid and unimpeded
humanitarian access to those in need
the space for humanitarian action must
be restored and protected in a way that
ensures continuous and sustained
humanitarian access
civilians must be protected at all times
ceasefire agreements and so-called
humanitarian corridors to evacuate
civilians can be measured for this
purpose
evacuation of civilians must be safe
voluntary and to destination of their
own choosing
unclear agreements won't meet the needs
of the civilian population
those civilians who are leaving
and also those civilians who are
remaining
must be protected
we commend the neighboring countries for
keeping the borders open and for the
great generosity and solidarity shown
with people fleeing the conflict
the door to safety and protection must
remain open without discrimination
we also condemn all the
command all the humanitarian
organizations and in particular the
local organizations for their heroic
efforts to deliver life-saving aid
medical and humanitarian workers must be
protected they are not a target
president
norway condemns russia's massive
military aggression against ukraine
ukraine we reiterate our call on russia
to withdraw its troops immediately and
stop causing further deaths suffering
and destruction
the
7.5 million children of ukraine are
seeing the places they live
play and learn being damaged and
destroyed
their lives and future are at stake
this war must stop now
dialogue and diplomacy are the only way
forward thank you
i thank the representative of norway for
her statement and i give the floor to
the representative of china
thank you madam president
madam president
first of all i wish to thank usg
griffiths
and
executive director russell for their
respective briefings
we
remain concerned
about the rapidly changing situation in
ukraine and deeply deplore the
increasing number of civilian casualties
we appeal for the maximum degree of
restraint and intensification of
diplomatic efforts
so as to put an early end to the fight
ensure the protection of civilian life
and their property and their basic needs
and prevent the emergence of a
large-scale humanitarian crisis
russia and ukraine have
reached a consensus through negotiation
on the establishment of humanitarian
corridors we hope the parties will
overcome the difficulties
encountered in the implementation of
this consensus so as to ensure that
those corridors are safe and smooth
china's state council and foreign
minister today put forward a six-point
initiative on the situation in ukraine
first
the humanitarian operations
must strictly abide by the principle of
humanity neutrality and impartiality in
accordance with the ga resolution 46-182
in order to prevent the politicization
of humanitarian
issues second full attention should be
given to all those displaced inside and
from ukraine most important in
particular is to provide humanitarian
assistance to those countries hosting
these people and to help with their
purpose shelter third is the protection
of civilians in particular protection of
vulnerable groups of women children
elderly and people with disability
and efforts should be made to avoid the
emergence of a secondary humanitarian
disasters inside ukraine such as food
shortage and spread infectious diseases
fourth efforts should be made to
guarantee safe and smooth humanitarian
operations including providing
rapid safe and unhindered humanitarian
access
and ensure the safety and security of a
medical personnel and humanitarian
personnel exclusively engaged in medical
duties
and protected the medical equipment and
transportation used in humanitarian
operations and a critical civilian
infrastructure
fifth is to ensure the safety of foreign
nationals in ukraine allowing their safe
guaranteed and unrestricted departure
from ukraine
and to help them return to their home
country
is to support united nations
coordinating role in channeling
humanitarian assistance in ukraine and
to support the work of the united
nations crisis coordinator for ukraine
during the course of organizing chinese
nationals seeking refuge and evacuation
we have received friendly assistance
from the government and the different
sectors of society in ukraine and
countries including russia moldova
romania poland hungary slovakia and
belarus have also provided
valued support here we wish to express
our heartfelt thanks to the government
people of these countries
madam president
but the situation in ukraine has
deteriorated to where it is today as due
to a combination of complex factors to
resolve complex issues what is required
is common reason rather than adding fuel
to the flame
which will only lead to escalation to
resolve the
crisis in ukraine it is imperative to
abide by the principles and the purposes
of the u.n charter respect
and ensure the sovereignty and the
territorial integrity of countries and
to
abide by the principle of indivisibility
of security and address reasonable
security concerns of the country's
concern of the parties concerned it is
imperative to stick to dialogue
negotiation undefined
a
resolution to the dispute through
peaceful means any action that is
conducive to easing the situation under
political settlement we receive china
support any action that is not
conducive to promoting a diplomatic
solution under which in essence means
adding
means fanning and fueling the flame
leading to escalation will be met with
china's opposition
we are deeply concerned at the
intensifying unilateral sanctions
sanctions are not an effective means to
finding lasting solutions to the
question to the issue in question on the
contrary they will create disastrous
humanitarian consequences and their
spillover effect will only create damage
and loss to other countries
importing offensive weapons into ukraine
and sending mercenaries may further
worsen the situation and create more and
bigger risks
china will continue to speak for peace
and to work for peace we encourage
russia and ukraine to continue with
their direct negotiations and we express
the hope that their talks are fruitful
where peace can be created
china has always been committed to
creating peace through negotiations on
the second day of the conflict
in an arranged phone call with president
putin president xi jinping already
expressed his wish that
russia and ukraine will hold peace talks
as soon as possible to which president
putin responded positively
china is also willing when the time
requires
to join the international community to
carry out necessary good offices we also
encourage the united states nato eu to
carry in equal and equal dialogue with
russia and to face up to the antagonism
and and problems that had been
accumulating for years
and pay high attention to the negative
effect
to the security environment for russia
resulted from the continuous eastward
expansion of nato and in accordance with
the principle of invisibility of
security to seek to establish an
european
security mechanism that is balanced
effective and sustainable thank you
madam president
i thank the representative of china for
their statement i shall now make a
statement in my capacity as the
representative of the united arab
emirates
i would like at the outset to thank mr
martin griffith the under secretary
general for humanitarian affairs and
emergency relief coordinator and ms
catherine russell executive director of
unicef for their briefings
as the speakers ahead of me have noted
the humanitarian situation in ukraine
has reached catastrophic levels
today more than 40 million ukrainians
including 7.5 million children face
insecurity
damaged and destroyed infrastructure
and a severe lack of basic services
as
there are nearly 1.7 million ukrainians
who are either internally displaced or
refugees while the number of casualties
continues to rise
considering these grim facts we must as
an international community try to
urgently alleviate the humanitarian
suffering of ukrainians
as we intensify our efforts to end the
fighting and find a permanent solution
to the current crisis
i would like to focus on the following
issues
we call on all parties to respect their
obligations under international
humanitarian law
this includes
ensuring foremost that civilians and
civilian objects
including schools and hospitals are not
the target of attacks
we further note that the destruction of
ukrainian infrastructure is severely
affecting humanitarian conditions
with access to urgent services such as
water health services and food supplies
is increasingly difficult
humanitarian aid must reach those in
need without precondition on any
ceasefire agreements
the safety of humanitarian personnel
must also be ensured
we stressed the need to stop hostilities
to allow affected civilians
to leave cities exposed to violence
including mario paul kharkiv and sumi
we deeply regret the collapse of the
humanitarian corridors that have been
agreed
and recognize that humanitarian
corridors are temporary and imperfect
solutions they are not an alternative to
respect for international humanitarian
law however properly established
humanitarian corridors can be an
immediate measure
as we explore every way
that can contribute to the protection of
civilians
there is an urgent need for realistic
initiatives that can contribute to
building confidence between the
conflicting parties and to ensuring
respect for international humanitarian
law for example the remains of the dead
should be identified and respected and
whenever possible their return should be
arranged
protected persons including wounded sick
and captured soldiers are due protection
by the parties under international
humanitarian law
we call on the international community
to intensify efforts to urgently provide
humanitarian support to ukraine this
includes contributing to the un
humanitarian flash appeal
and the ukraine regional refugee
response plan as well as other
initiatives
in this regard we commend the role of
the united nations secretariat in
supporting and coordinating the
humanitarian response which should focus
particularly on women and children
we also commend the efforts made by
neighboring countries in receiving
fleeing ukrainians
the uae will provide 5 million u.s
dollars to alleviate the suffering of
ukrainians additionally we sent
30 metric tons of emergency and medical
and relief aid to ukraine today
in conclusion we stressed that finding a
solution to the crisis and avoiding
further damage and casualties requires
a restraint
and an immediate ceasefire throughout
ukraine
it also requires activating diplomatic
channels to find a sustainable solution
that ends the conflict we welcome the
continued high-level engagement of the
international community with each of the
parties we believe such efforts will
contribute to a diplomatic solution in a
manner that serves the goal of
maintaining
regional and international peace and
security and protects the dignity and
needs of millions of civilians thank you
i resume my function as president of the
council
i now give the floor to the
representative of ukraine
madam president distinguished members of
the council
mr under secretary general
madam executive director
12 days of all-out russian invasion in
ukraine including from the
territory of belarus
have brought us on the brink of
humanitarian catastrophe of potentially
global nature
i would like to thank all countries who
accept
the ukrainian refugees and led other
foreign nationals to their territory
as we have already heard more than 1.7
million people
mostly women and children have already
fled from the war
unleashed
unprovoked
by russia
in saxon house and in germany
in the spring of 1942
an extermination unit was built in the
industrial yard
with a crematorium
and the next shot unit
with a gas chamber added in 1943
the ss cynically named this building
station z
or station zed
z
is a letter that russian military
is putting on their vehicles departing
to ukraine
some interpret z
as
zapabido in
russian or
for victory
in english
some say it is
zapad in russian or west
in english
i would insist it is
the
for zvery
or animals or rather beasts
in english
russia continues to cynically disregard
the norms of international humanitarian
law during hostilities
russian troops block numerous attempts
of the ukrainian authorities to evacuate
civilians
through humanitarian corridors
they denied access
of international organizations to
provide humanitarian assistance to the
most affected places
it is even more appalling
that the russian troops opened firing on
evacuees and evacuation vehicles
shall the roads allocated for
humanitarian corridors
for instance for instance they shelled
the depots with evacuation buses near
mariupol
blew up railway near european in the
kiev region to prevent evacuation by
train
destroyed the bridge on the way to
walnut
all the mentioned were the main routes
to evacuate civilians
as it was stated today by the ministry
of foreign affairs of ukraine i quote
today in violation of the previously
reached agreements the russian
federation yet again disrupted the
opening of the humanitarian corridors
for evacuation of the civilian
population from the besieged cities of
the suburbs of kiev
donetsk and her son regions
russia's armed forces continue bombing
and missile attacks on kiev mario paul
varnavaha sumi mikalai kharkiv and other
cities towns and villages
this prevents the safe exit of
humanitarian convoys carrying ukrainian
and foreign citizens as well as delivery
of medications and food end of quote
today the hearings on the ukraine's
lawsuit against russia
in genocide case have been commenced
at the u.n international court of
justice
as an immediate action ukraine appeals
to the icj
to impose the precautionary measures in
this case in order to stop
the bloodshed
we condemn russians and willingness to
fully implement the un general assembly
resolution
on aggression against ukraine in
particular to immediately cease
its use of force against ukraine in fact
russia does not
fully implement it doesn't implement it
at all
first of all russia must stop violating
the ceasefire arrangements aimed and
ensuring rapid safe and unhindered
passage through humanitarian corridors
it must put an end to spreading this
information and manipulating the lives
of civilians
evacuations through humanitarian
corridors is only possible when the
ceasefire regime is fully upheld
the ukrainian side is ready
for that we also consider as
inappropriate any attempts by moscow to
force civilians both ukrainian citizens
and foreigners
in the besieged cities to flee to the
territory of russia and belarus
taking into account high probability of
provocations in particular
taking those evacuated as hostages or
using them by the russian armed forces
as a human shield
it looks especially cynical when
european borders are widely open for
refugees from ukraine
and i totally agree with my friend
nicola who set his pure hypocrisy to
push ukrainians to belarus or to russia
ukraine calls on the member states to
spare no effort
in forcing russia to uphold the
ceasefire regime in order to open
humanitarian corridors and prevent a
large-scale humanitarian catastrophe
life is very dynamic
and unfortunately while we were sitting
here and discussing our business
another appalling example of russia's
disregard
of its own commitments on humanitarian
corridors has taken place
just now
according to available information from
my capital russia has undermined
arrangements on humanitarian corridors
for tomorrow
and i regret my dear ambassadors all of
you who called me today when discussed
this business
it was the arrangement was made and it
was broken by the russians
despite a route through poltava
being agreed
including with the icrc
russian side has already sent us a
letter
with roots to russia and belarus only
i call on the russian side
to reverse to the previously agreed
routes to allow ukrainian and foreign
citizens
to leave for europe
today more than hundreds more than
hundreds of ukrainian cities and
villages
attacked and sieged by the aggressor
state
and they are on the verge of
humanitarian disaster the population
does not have access to drinking water
food medicine electricity
heating and other basic
necessities much of the
environment
environmental damage inflicted on
ukraine by the russian invasion will
likely prove
irreparable
in the in near future
the chernobyl disaster of 1986 teaches
us that the effects of nuclear accidents
endure for hundreds and and even
thousands of years
the co2 being released as a result of
russia's scorched
earth tactics will likewise linger in
the atmosphere for the long term
compounding the effects on climate
change
and green greenhouse effect
so for ukraine has been one
of the guarantors of global food
security so far i apologize
now this status is challenged by the
russian war against ukraine
the implications at the global level
will be catastrophic
just a few examples
55 percent of sunflower oil
exported worldwide
comes from ukraine 55 percent
sixty percent of ukrainian agricultural
products
are exported through seaports
the closure of poors and the sea by the
russian army threatens the global supply
chain
it means that defending ukraine from the
russian aggression also
protects the world from hunger
given that russian leadership attempts
to conceal real losses
and resolutely denies any discussions on
the ways to return
their soldiers bodies ukraine is facing
additional threat of the health crisis
we are speaking about dozens of
thousands of bodies decomposing in the
fields of ukraine bodies of the russian
soldiers
in this regard we call on the icrc to
set up a database of falling occupiers
prisoners of all
on the basis of the central
investigation agency of the icrc
as well as to provide assistance in
returning the remains of the following
occupiers
to russia
according to the ministry of education
more than 211 ukrainian schools have
been damaged or destroyed by the russian
military forces
since the beginning of the invasion
thousands of ukrainian children have
been deprived from their right to
education
according to the ministry of health of
ukraine as of march 6 34 hospitals were
destroyed
the world health organization has
reported
that six ukrainian doctors were killed
and 11 wounded as a result of the
russian shellings
given the threat of bombing and shelling
hospitals and maternity wards have moved
their patients to the basements
the country is running low on critical
medical supplies
therefore we call on all the u.n
humanitarian missions to act decisively
to respond to the growing humanitarian
crisis without delay
yesterday our occupants completely
destroyed the city airport of vinitza
it must be noted that the assistant
secretary general
u.n crisis coordinator for ukraine amin
award announced that vindica
was prepared to be a main hub to all u.n
humanitarian missions
distinguished members of the security
council
the russian occupiers are killing
ukrainian children
consciously
and cynically
at least 38 children have been already
killed since the russia's full-scale
armed aggression against ukraine
more than 70 kids were seriously wounded
due to the ongoing shelling of civilian
infrastructure in many cities this
number may be
increasing right now
ukraine deeply regrets
that more than 2 000 citizens of india
china
turkey
pakistan and other countries
safa today along with ukrainians from
russian aggression
the government of ukraine is in 24 7
contact with diplomatic missions and
consulates of foreign countries to
ensure that their citizens can safely
return to their countries as soon as
possible
the ministry of foreign affairs of
ukraine has established an emergency
hotline for foreign citizens wishing to
leave ukraine because of the russian
armed aggression
the ukrainian border guards in
cooperation with colleagues from
neighboring eu countries and moldova are
doing everything possible to speed up
the passage of all refugees from ukraine
and have never created obstacles that
would hinder this
we would like to reiterate that the only
root cause of ongoing massive
humanitarian crisis in ukraine
including the situation at the western
border of ukraine
is the armed aggression of the russian
federation against ukraine
russia bears full responsibility for the
killing and injuring of innocent people
destruction of civilian infrastructure
and obstacles for the safe departure of
ukrainians and foreign citizens
the government of ukraine works 24 7 to
set up the mechanisms for reliable
supplies of food medications and
essential commodities throughout the
country
on the second of march president
zielinski established the coordination
office on humanitarian and social issues
ukraine has received more than three
point
five hundred tons of humanitarian aid
and we are grateful to all our partners
for this manifestation of support
despite enemy attacks whole system
ensuring the proper functioning of the
state are intact
there is undeniable stability in the
work of the ukrainian government
despite the war minister of social
policy and pension fund have paid all
pensions to almost 13 million retired
citizens of ukraine
the government prepared an assistance
program for all ukrainians who have lost
their jobs as a result of war
private businesses and employees who
lost jobs due to war will receive
financial support in march
ukrainian railways started
procuring food fuel medicines
electricity and other important goods
and services
for the for the population
the enterprise will be in close contact
with military administrations and
address
to address the most pressing needs of
people and the state
dear colleagues in ukraine
people in ukraine value the worst of
support
at the same time they require concrete
actions to save their lives their health
their property
it is also already clear to everyone
that the fragility of the situation
reaches beyond ukraine into europe and
across the world
we expect that the council
to be decisive
in responding to the worst humanitarian
crisis we have ever seen
since the end of the second world war
in europe
you know before i conclude
one of my colleagues
after the last security council session
said you know
the colleague said it looks like a group
therapy
we are all here
trying to bring to sanity
one member
and indeed when i
listen to this member
to this
representative of that country
i think it's absolutely right that the
department of health of the of the city
of new york is called department of
health
and mental hygiene
because it's very difficult
after these meetings
where we listen
to the
persistent lies
and delusion
delirium
coming from that particular
country
i think that it's not only the russian
diplomats in new york who need
mental assistance but also
those who post it today this text
foreign minister lavrov
the goal of russia's special military
operation
is to stop
any war that could take place
on ukrainian territory
or that could start from there
russian embassy in london
retweeted by the russian foreign
ministry
let me remind the russian diplomats
that in london in case of need for
mental help you can dial nhs line one
one
i thank the representative of ukraine
for their statement
the representative of the russian
federation is asking for the floor i
give the floor to the representative of
the russian federation
thank you very much madam president
i take the floor
not to polemicize with the
representative of ukraine i have another
objective
although of course
i have some words to say
the ukrainian representative interpreted
the letter zed
on russian military hardware that is now
in ukraine
as
beasts or
wild animals
we have our opinion about who the
animals are
the representatives of the armed forces
in the ukrainian armed forces who for
eight years have terrorized the milit
the civilian population in donbass and
this is continuing of course now they
are bombarding lugansk
and other regions in the donbass
breaking off the operation to evacuate
people through the humanitarian
corridors but
everything is actually quite the country
it's the ukrainians who won't agree to
our proposals to on a ceasefire
and won't exit allow people to exit
through these corridors even though
we've already said that these national
battalions are holding people hostage in
these towns they're like human shields
they're putting military technology in
in accommodation box
there was also a post on on
on
on telegram about an issue related to
this about trying to use the the m23
[Music]
affairs in ukraine
i won't read it out completely
we will broadcast this statement
in the near future among members of the
security council
but it says that the russian party is
once again saying that tomorrow the 8th
of march
at 10 in the morning in moscow time
to carry out a ceasefire and to open
humanitarian humanitarian corridors to
evacuate citizens from kiev chernigov
sumi
kakov and mariupol
my uk my ukrainian colleagues said that
ukraine is ready to work in this
direction
but let's see what answer we get to this
proposal from the russian authorities
incidentally
this proposal
doesn't have any demands
there's also evacuation offered towards
ukrainian cities to the west of kiev
and ultimately
it will be the choice of the the people
themselves where they want to be
evacuated to but i don't want to comment
on the last statement by the
representative of ukraine
i simply
don't really know
how it is that he is so familiar with
the
the authorities that deal with mental
health here i'd like to know about that
in more detail thank you
i thank the representative of the
russian federation for their statement
there are no more names inscribed on the
list of speakers
i will now adjourn the meeting so that
the council can continue its discussion
on the subject in closed consultations
i would kindly ask all observers to
promptly exit the chamber directly upon
the adjournment of the meeting
the meeting is adjourned